the war chosen by one man to be very
blunt
let us speak plainly
permanent member of the United Nations
security Council invaded its neighbor
attempted to erase a sovereign state
from the map
Russia has shamelessly violated the
court tenants of the United Nations
Charter
no more important
than the clear prohibition
against countries taking the territory
of their neighbor by force
again just today
President Putin has made over nuclear
threats against Europe
and a reckless disregard
for the responsibilities of the
non-proliferation regime
now
Russia's calling calling up more
soldiers to join the fight
and the Kremlin is organizing a sham
referendum try to Annex parts of Ukraine
and extremely significant violation of
the U.N Charter
this world should see these Outrageous
Acts for what they are
Putin claims he had to act
because Russia was threatened
but no one threatened Russia
and no one other than Russia
sought conflict
in fact
we warned it was coming
and with many of you we worked to try to
avert it
Putin's own words
make his true purpose unmistakable
just before he invaded Putin asserted
and I quote Ukraine was created by
Russia and never had quote real
statehood
and now we see
tax on schools
Railway stations hospitals
one on centers of Ukrainian history and
culture
in the past
even more horrifying evidence of
Russia's atrocity and war crimes
Mass Graves uncovered in ism
bodies according to those of escalated
those bodies showing signs of torture
this war
is about extinguishing Ukraine's right
to exist as a state
plain and simple
and Ukraine's right to exist as a people
whoever you are
wherever you live
whatever you believe
that should not that should make your
blood run cold
that's why 141 nations in the general
assembly
came together
and not to unequivocally condemn
Russia's war against Ukraine